one of the few people in the media who
is in the corporate media I would say
who is fighting and constantly asking
the right questions uh is Peter Ducey
over at Fox News so he asked uh Corinne
Jean-Pierre on Thursday about what's
going on here and then on these
documents how could anyone be that
irresponsible
isn't that what this President says
about mishandling classified documents
the president spoke to this personally
he spoke to this personally he but again
he believes that classified documents
and information should be taken
seriously he takes them seriously and he
was surprised to learn by any any record
he just says absolutely nothing she's so
perfect for this job in in these
whack-a-doodle times that we live in
because she says absolutely nothing she
uses a lot of words and says nothing
right it's just awful because we want
some level of truth but her job is to
actually deflect us from the truth so
then what happened that was on Thursday
what happened when uh Peter Ducey tried
to ask a follow-up question on Friday
thanks everybody
[Music]
Peter with his hand up over there at the
end yeah she didn't answer any questions
from Peter on uh on that day here's
Peter I believe a day before that asking
Biden directly what he was thinking
classified material next to your
let me uh we're going to get a chance to
speak on all this God willing soon but
as I said earlier this week
people and by the way my Corvette's in a
lock garage okay so it's not like you're
sitting out in the street but anyway
foreign
yes as well as my Corvette first off
that he thinks his Corvette is more
important than the classified documents
is absolutely hilarious and either way
the documents aren't supposed to be
there it doesn't matter if you put them
in the lock garage next to the Corvette
or rather you put them in your bedroom
under the bed where you keep the uh the
doll that you're sniffing none of that
matters the point is you're not allowed
to have these things in the first place
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]